bonjour thomas porte merci de répondre à
nos questions brune poirson chez accor
je vous inspire quoi
c'est un peu le symbole de ce
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro quand vous
l'avez rappelé d'entre passa juste avant
c'est à dire un aller retour entre le
public et le privé où on a des députés
des élus qui quittent leur mandat pour
lequel il aurait été élu pour aller
travailler dans des grosses entreprises
privées des gros salaires je rappelle
quand même que brune % elle a été
aperçue je crois si fois la famille
nationale depuis septembre 2000 veine
avec 7200 euros nets
donc c'est quand même dans un moment où
une période où on impose des politiques
d'austérité on est en train de détruire
la science sur l'âge où on met à bas
tout ce qui fait la richesse de notre
pays on ne tient pas sur les plus
pauvres on voit que les ministres et les
députés
quand ils en ont marre de faire de la
politique c'est ce qu'ils disent vont se
placer dans les plus grandes entreprises
en mettant au service de celle ci leur
carnet d adresses on a quand même eu
cette semaine une révélation c'est à
dire qu'ils avaient 223 députés la
république en marche et modem qui s'est
engagé à rendre publics leurs agendas et
notamment les rendez vous avec les
lobbystes c'est le 43 l'ont fait donc on
voit qu'il ya véritablement un confit
d'intérêt
un conflit entre ce qui est de servir
l'intérêt général et la mission de
l'état et après d'aller dans des
entreprises privées qui n'ont pas du
tout les intérêts vous parlez du conflit
d'intérêts elle poursuit en parallèle
une mission parlementaire sur le thème
de l'environnement concilier des
missions dans les secteurs privé et
public au niveau étatique selon vous
c'est pas faisable c'est ça non c'est
absolument pas faisable c'est
contradictoire
vous comprenez bien que avoir une
mission au sein du gouvernement pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et le développement durable à
être directrice d'un service de très
haut niveau chez coop
ces deux fonctions qui sont
incompatibles elle va pouvoir servir les
intérêts d'accord de par sa position à
l'intérêt du gouvernement et des
informations auxquelles elle a accès et
aujourd'hui c'est la puissance publique
qui est mis sous la coupe de ses grands
groupes là parce que c'est pas la
première vous l'avez aussi cité à vendre
on a de plus en plus de grands groupes
qui vont chercher des gens qui ont été
dans la politique qui ont des carnets d
adresses qui ont les informations qu'ils
se servent à près de ces moyens là pour
faire prospérer leur entreprise vous
avez cité aucun but bernard squarcini
chez lvmh quelqu'un utiliser des gens
qui travaillaient à l'intérieur des
services de l'état faire de l'espionnage
sur françois ruffin donc c'est quand
même extrêmement problématique
c'est un dévoiement total de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui notamment la mission de
servir l'état
c'est pour ça qu'on demande c'est une
période qui interdisent wii les icônes
des travaux transféré de du public au
privé
en gros quand vous avez exercé une
mission de députés ou dans un
gouvernement
vous ne devriez pas pouvoir travailler
dans le privé pendant deux ou trois
années après pour garantir une certaine
équité et pas multiplié les conflits
d'intérêts parce que aujourd'hui ça qui
est à l'heure c'est un véritable conflit
d'intérêts et après on s'étonne qu'ils
aient des décisions qui soient prises
qui soit contraire à l'intérêt général
et qui répondent aux intérêts des lobbys
mais quand vous avez un tel une telle
passerelles entre les deux ce n'est pas
surprenant au final on parle de ce qui
se passe du côté de la république en
marge par rapport à ses pantoufles âge
mais il ya d'autres personnalités de
droite de gauche également vous êtes de
gauche vous pensez quoi de du recyclage
entre guillemets de certaines
personnalités comme myriam el khomri
arnaud montebourg cécile duflot najat
vallaud belkacem ou encore bernard
cazeneuve tous les bords politiques
finalement sont concernés mais je crois
qu'il ya deux choses différentes et
cécile duflot par exemple pour ne citer
qu'elles avant d'être directrice
d'auxonne
aujourd'hui elle a quitté la vie
politique et elle est restée en retrait
pendant un certain nombre d'années avant
de reprendre une fonction dans une
association qui est d'intérêt général et
qui luttent pour une des missions
d'intérêt général
là on parle de grands groupes privés
travailler au sein d'une association et
au travail au sein d'un grand groupe
privé je rappelle quelques accords c'est
le sixième groupe hôtelier mondial qui a
continué à verser des dividendes qu'à
licencier des gens qui est propriétaire
de l'hôtel ibis par exemple à paris à
batignolles où les femmes de ménages
sont en grève depuis 20 mois donc c'est
ça dont il s'agit c'est pas du tout la
même chose
donc aujourd'hui on voit que ces gens là
se servent des mandats qu'ils ont pour
aller siéger dans des grandes
entreprises et en gros ils sont passés
aux ils sont passés dans le gouvernement
ils ont acquis un certain nombre de
choses un certain nombre de carnet d
adresses certain nombre de liens qui
leur permet à près de la gare si dans le
privé il n'hésiterait pas étonnant que
dans deux ou trois ans on les retrouve
venir dans le public parce qu'à cet
aller-retour qui est incessant et après
on ya une confusion des démissions une
confusion des intérêts les intérêts
quand vous êtes dans le gouvernement ou
qu'on vous donne un grand coup privé se
sont pas les mêmes thomas porte si vous
deviez devenir député ou ministre
récit une société privée souhaité par la
suite vous débauchez moyennant un joli
chèque vous diriez non sans me faire
l'avocat du diable c'est pas un peu
humain finalement d'aller voir si
l'herbe n'est pas plus verte ailleurs
non mais vous savez déjà
aujourd'hui je suis dans la position des
députés mais j'ai toujours travaillé
dans la fonction publique et dans le
service public depuis que j'ai commencé
à travailler la sortie de mes études
c'est une question de vocation de
sensibilité il n'est pas aujourd'hui
question de dire qu'il faut pas aller
travailler dans le privé où on n'a pas
droit d'avoir un poste à responsabilités
qui bien rémunérés dans le privé c'est
pas ça qu'on dit c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
peut pas être à la direction de grands
groupes privés
juste après avoir servi l'état où on a
été au coeur des décisions sensibles
si demain on a un ministre de l'énergie
un ministre de l'environnement qui
devient par exemple président ou
directeur général d'edf
quelle va être la décision d'edf par
rapport à ce qui a été décidé dans les
cabinets ministériels de l'état comment
on va mettre tout ça en parallèle c'est
ça aujourd'hui qui est un jeu 6 2 mais
on avance et passerelles qui continue on
a une confusion démission je le redis
vous appelez à une période de latence
entre une fonction dans le politique
dont le public est une fonction dans le
privé donc selon vous est ce qu'il
faudrait alors à ce compte-là légiférer
pour éviter donc le pantouflage et ainsi
favoriser la loyauté des politiques
vis-à-vis de leurs fonctions oui je
pense qu'il ya je pense qu'aujourd'hui
pour contraindre celles et ceux qui
pratiquent ça et en vérité vous avez
raison de le dire c'est pas nouveau ça
fait quand même des années que convoi
qui se passe des choses comme ça il
faudrait avoir une décision législative
qui disent que sur une certaine période
alors moi j'ai pas la réponse mais vous
réfléchir à deux trois quatre ans voir
comment on fait quand on a été un
serviteur de l'état qu'on a été élu par
des citoyens pour exercer un mandat
politique nationale on ne doit pas
exercer dans une grande entreprise
privée ce n'est pas possible c'est
incompatible aujourd'hui et ça remet en
cause les missions d'intérêt général et
les missions de service public de l'état
et sa des voix les décisions qui sont
prises et les intérêts des citoyens
merci thomas porte pour avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le porte parole du mouvement générations
présidée par benoît
hamon